bonsoir ainsi à contre-courant un film
très très onirique un style tout à fait
particulier peut-être un contrôle
emploie aussi pour à la bâche ou non oui
et en même temps je je suis je me sens
assez proche de ce genre de philosophie
politique un peu quand j'ai lu le
scénario je je relisais arthaud c'est
une sorte d' illuminé qui passait pour
un fou de l'extérieur pour les autres et
lui étaient persuadés d'être d'avoir
trouvé l'idéal vrai et le rôle c'est un
peu ça et les deux personnages un
instituteur qui arrive en chine mais
auparavant il a essayé d'être
missionnaire il a voulu avoir une vie
idéale un amour idéal avec avec l'au
delà presque et 7
cette aventure cet arrêté et il a voulu
retrouver en chine un peu ce c'est idéal
c'est un besoin d'absolu totale du
problème et aventure ils te poussent ses
dividendes en scénario jeu je trouve que
je pense un peu par ce qui manque ou ce
qui devrait exister au cinéma donc ya
pas tellement de films sur la poésie ou
sur un peu les rationnels on mélangera
un peu la réalité et le rêve
oui parce qu'on veut tous expliquez vous
alors c'est des films uniquement
d'actions ou donc c'est parce que ça
manquait dans le paysage je trouve donc
je suis très heureux de l'avoir fait à
ce qui est tout à fait étonnant c'est
que tout au long du film ya une
véritable transformation physique de
votre part peu à peu vous devenez
asiatique si je puis dire
est ce que vous l'avez ressenti vous
même au plus profond de vous même c'est
c'est à dire que la pression de
l'extérieur est tellement forte
je parle des chinois et ils sont ils
sont ils sont nombreux et c'est ça
grouille ya du bruit en fait et vous
êtes pour recevez ça comme ça dans la
tête c'est un moyen de se faire accepter
ou un peu de leur ressembler parce que
en tant que blanc comme ça occidental je
crois qu'ils sont assignés par notre
technologie
mais ce qu'on pense je crois qu'ils s'en
foutent ils ont leur façon de concevoir
la vie ou la mort et moi même à un
moment donné je partais du principe
qu'un chinois était peut-être le l'homme
le plus fort au monde et il fallait se
fait il y avait des techniciens chinois
il fallait se faire accepter par eux
aussi parce que et en me voyant
cravacher au fur et à mesure que le film
avance et émeut plus d'estimé pour moi
et jusque cassés se séparer en larmes à
la fin je crois oui oui vraiment dans
parce que on est arrivé il y avait la
mousson
donc il pleuvait toujours très fort et
les routes étaient cassés en fait et
ensuite il faisait 45 degrés donc tout
le monde est tombé malade en fait donc
il ya eu pas mal de péripéties
qu'est ce que vous aimez dans le cinéma
par rapport au music hall alors est-ce
que ce que je trouve assez simple pour
moi c'est de d'entrer dans le rêve de
quelqu'un ou dans son fantasme parce que
je j'écris des chansons donc je sais mon
univers je je pourrais avoir tendance à
me complaire complètement là dedans je
crois que c'est assez sain de temps en
temps de dalé dans le ce premier dans le
rêve de quelqu'un et pour aboutir un
schéma là vous y arrivez très bien merci
dans ma soeur chinoise c'est un film
d'alain barza et qui est sorti donc
aujourd'hui au cinéma sur les grands
écrans merci beaucoup